[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hall of famer two-time nba champ
ten-time all-star ray allen joining us
on the program
wow i like what you and your wife have
done with uh the uh
the house there whose room are you in
i'm in my 14 year old son walker's room
uh
this is definitely uh new to me uh
construction in the house so i had to uh
kind of move around a little bit what's
the coolest thing in your son's room
um
it's probably his shoes he's got a box
of shoes
stacked
so all his favorite shoes are in his
room so you know there's sneaker heads
so i'm going to guess he's got a lot of
uh air jordans in there
yeah he definitely does but the problem
dan is
he's 14 like he's got so many shoes he
can't wear you know so i find myself
always trying to you know figure out a
friend or family to give them away and
they're really nice sneakers so
first world problem i guess
did you ever get a pair of shoes from
jordan himself
uh from the company yes
but not well actually let me let me
refrain like i've been to his house in
jupiter
and you know you when you walk through
his house you go into uh when you're
coming in there's a transition area
where the garage is and he's got a
closet with all these golf shoes in
there and you know jordan wears a size
13 so
you know
i had to squeeze in some of them
now did you say can i have a pair of
your golf shoes
mike um
i did
you know without any uh
embarrassment because there were shoes
that nobody else had or ever seen before
this was you know now you can go online
and you can find a lot of jordan golf
students but if you go back about six
seven years
he's making all these shoes that have uh
that are basketball shoes
running shoes that are have golf
soles on them so i nobody's ever seen it
before so i was like i got to have these
shoes and so i didn't wear i stuck my
foot foot in there no sock squeezing
into 13. okay if you go into jordan's
house
do you know that the greatest basketball
player of all time lives there
yes
yes
how can you tell
well i mean there's segments of the
house that i should say that you can
tell but for the most part when you walk
in you don't know okay you know i you
know so when you you're in certain parts
of it but for the most part it's pretty
pretty non-descript uh it's it's pretty
uh pretty grandiose uh which you know
he's got so many rooms which is it's
fascinating just kind of walk through it
okay what's the coolest thing you saw in
jordan's house
um
you know just you know the way he he
lives kind of outside in the back you
know so he could put the screen down so
he can protect it from the mosquitoes so
he's sitting outside always you know
watching games watching tv
and uh
yeah yeah humidor sitting right there so
such a cool space and you know i want to
try to create that in my home right
you know in florida you got to live that
way you got to have a space outdoors
where you can watch tv uh on sundays and
obviously in the evening
i remember talking to you about this if
you did a sequel with spike lee on he
got game and i thought that you and
spike were talking uh about the
possibility of maybe kind of revisiting
this with zion williamson is there any
traction on that
well uh we have talked with uh several
uh younger players uh including women
because there's definitely a
dynamic there
if you think about since 1998 uh when
the movie he got game came out
there's been so many storylines you know
in the last you know under
you know 23 24 years and so there's so
many different ways that we could take
this uh but
i think the one caveat for us uh spike
and i we talk about every time is making
sure trying to figure out a way to get
denzel involved uh because i i think
until equalizer two he was against doing
sequels
you know so then equalizer two came out
so we're like oh we have a chance uh so
i think that's the
the main thing is to get him excited and
get him on board so we could uh because
it's just not the same uh if he wasn't
or he didn't have something to do with
the movie uh with the part part two i
like the girl aspect of this
i mean with wnba name image likeness
like that it just feels like
um
there's a lot of different things you
could explore in something like that now
and then having a a woman or uh you know
a female is the lead would be pretty
cool
yeah and there's
if you think about uh
sports still the story of sport can
still be told through a
female perspective there's been so many
great stories uh with
renee montgomery and uh in atlanta and
now have ownership and team and you know
everything that's going on with the
black lives movement um
there's just so much and
you know being able to to kind of
point a a limelight at
the women's game you know it certainly
could help uh grow that sport just the
same
your son uh walker has type one diabetes
uh what was the news like when you found
that out
well it was 2008 in the nba finals we
were playing against the lakers uh and
it was devastating because i was getting
ready uh for for games five
and
you know that whole week he had been
you know kind of in and out we thought
maybe he had the flu and um
you know we
i told shannon my wife before the game
uh that the day before i said just take
him to the hospital in the morning and
just get him checked so that morning she
took him to the
to the doctor in the hospital we were
staying uh over in beverly hills uh and
the team was separate from the families
and so she took home the guy said take
him to the hospital and make sure you
get his blood checked you know don't
leave without getting his blood checked
and without that walker wouldn't be
with us today because the blood can rule
out a lot of scary things
and um
you know
he
it diabetes mask itself as the flu
so when you're thinking about
uh you know
common symptoms of
diabetes are bedwetting lethargy
vomiting
weight loss weight gain
headaches
it masks itself as the flu and when you
you have a child that's going through
those symptoms a lot of people will tell
you i was going around and the
misdiagnosis can can result in a lot of
people
um not waking up with their children the
next day so it's important that we
talked about this it's important that
you know even now while i'm here today
is to to
you know talk about our our great
partnership with abbott because abbott
has come out with the freestyle library
too which has allowed us to be able to
monitor you know walker's diabetes so
much easier you think about the
technology now that's existed uh over
the last over the last 20 years and you
know you're going on and on with people
with diabetes and now
you know we're able to track and monitor
his blood sugar numbers through an app
now uh so for anybody that wants to know
anything about uh freestyle library 2.
uh you can go on the freestyle
ebrary2.us and you can get that for free
from the app store
but it certainly helped us like right
now as i sit here i can go on my phone
and i can find out what walker's numbers
are currently so
it gives me a peace of mind gives my
wife peace of mind it enables us to kind
of help him grow a little bit better and
stronger you think he would have died if
this was
misdiagnosed
yeah he i would not be sitting in his
room right now
uh just thinking about we wouldn't have
known anything we would have just
mistook it as a flu and we just said go
sleep you know
and you know pound some fluids and his
blood sugar would have been going
through the roof so
i just implore every parent when you go
to the hospital like you have to
you know yeah we trust in doctors but we
at the same time we have to just
obviously follow the signs and make sure
that we be advocates and fight for our
children make sure that they test for
everything especially when you're trying
to figure out what is wrong with your
child it's spelled libre l-i-b-r-e
freestyle libre too
uh we're talking to real in the hall of
famer last time i had you on you were in
studio
and i
i tried to correct your shot
and i felt bad about it
i'm not going to apologize though ray
but i i'm not the first
i i
really
yeah no no over the course of my career
you get new coaches to come in and
they're like well why don't you try this
and
i'm like well i made the all-star team a
couple times it's been working for me
thus far so i'm just going to ride this
thing out
i i just remember because i was always
taught that you had the ball on your
fingertips you had the ball in the palm
of your hand
no i never had the ball in front of my
head
uh my remember i got i got big hands so
because this is what i stress to my guys
all day long like there's supposed to be
space in here it's got to be in your
fingertips and you don't want me to go
to the videotape right because you got
to go to the videotape
i was right there i was right there i i
was you know a foot away from your right
hand i said ray
it's on your it's on your palm on your
hand
no i've never put that i can't see with
the ball in palm like i know that's what
i tell you know all the other great
shooters that i come in contact with but
uh yeah it could you help ben simmons
how would you help ben simmons
uh well i
yeah i definitely could help him um
one you
people think about shooting is is some
talent that that you know some of the
best that's ever done it has
but it's just really just getting in
there and you you know in your mind you
have to think about the game you have to
think about you know
visualizing you know what it is that you
want to do
uh
what you foresee in your free throw so
you have to have a mindset to think
about these things and then kind of
absorb it and then do it
and so you know having the right
conversations first and foremost is
important for him and anybody that
struggles with shooting and then
it's like we have the saying like if you
have a full cup when you you walk into a
crowd somebody tries to pour something
in your cup you can't receive anything
more because you're already filled
so he's got to come to the table with an
empty cup and be willing to take all
this information you know for whatever
he's thought about shooting kind of
strip away
and break all it down and kind of
rebuild uh back up because you know one
thing it's you know how you hold the
ball in your hands it's got to be in
your fingertips so you don't have a push
shot
and you have to shoot shots that you
know you're going to be tested on in in
a game you know if you think about a
fourth quarter scenario with somebody
running out at you
how is that lift on your jump shot gonna
look what that what is that release
gonna look like and that's what you have
to practice
when you're in the gym by yourself
because you know far too often when i
walk in the gym i see kids just up there
just shooting with their upper body
and then it doesn't stand when you come
into a game situation because now you
have to measure a different release
point
and so you know with ben a lot of people
are running out
out at him and they're testing him to
make that shot so that was that is where
i would put him
in in a in a a gym environment a work
situation and have him
shoot under duress but how's his form no
ray
would you mess with his form
i don't think there's anything wrong
with his farm and what you have to
remember you know the one of the
greatest shooters i've ever seen in
reggie miller
you know he doesn't have form that was
taught you know
by any means when i first got into
league i thought to myself i was like
well it doesn't have to be perfect you
just have to know what it is that you're
working with
so with ben it you know it's not a form
thing it's about explaining to him
what it is that he's doing when he's
missing and where he wants his energy to
come from like he's gotta flow through
it he's a big guy
like when he shoots and he extends like
shooting comes from your feet all the
way through your body and then as you
release the ball
uh at your fingertips it's not just the
heave here
it's it's all one motion so that's why
for some of the the best shooters in the
world and and those that make it look so
easy
that's why it just looks like a flick
because you're using the motion from
from your toes all the way through your
fingertips can you step back just a
little bit on camera and and show the
audience what you mean when you're
saying because a lot of people you you
know you just practice the jumper up
here up top and yeah and what you're
saying like trae young and steph curry
aren't big guys but they're they utilize
their legs so well so can you stand up
and just show us what what like where
you're if you're watching on uh radio or
listening on radio we apologize so all
right so show me what you mean so
you know when you look at steph steph
and trey they do have more of a push
shot
so when you when you come down even my
shot i come from here
and then i go up and my motion pushes me
and pulls me and i shoot the ball and
release so it's just uh
a flick so you when you see guys coming
in transition as they run and then they
stop you see a lot of people kill their
their their energy or their motion and
they just push right here
so what i want to get guys to understand
is when they run
and then they take off
don't let that uh that energy that
inertia die at your feet at your lower
body and where they just start pushing
with their upper body
so it's important
and i'm also wondering about this ray it
feels like you're seeing shooters maybe
down a little bit lower
whereas we were taught to be a little
bit higher with the release point these
longer shots
it feels like these guys yeah they're
starting down at their chest like are
you teaching that to your your kids
well
one of the things that's fascinating
even with my son walker this is where
his shot is and his release is so low
because you have to remember for them
the ball is bigger so they have to use
more muscle and more of their body to
get the ball up and they're not in their
wrists with the shot so
it's super important to kind of gauge
that's why everybody you know i put
videos of my sons up when i'm working
them out over summer
and you know the younger ones i don't
mess with their jump shot because
they'll get on the trampoline because
they have a hoop on their trampoline
with a small ball and they'll shoot it
just like this
and perfect form rotation everything but
when they get the big ball they have to
push it from here because
they don't have the strength and then
what happens is as a kid gets older this
is where their release is because they
haven't
evolved and you know reconstructed where
their jump shot is just where they're
comfortable
so
that that's what i think happens with a
lot of kids in their jump shooting is
that they shoot one way when they're
younger to get the ball up and they
heave it and they never change or get to
their
somewhat teenage years to their adult
body where they're shooting the shot
that is conducive to them being now
strong enough so i tell all the kids i'm
in the gym with i said listen
you're not in middle school anymore you
have the strength in your wrists and
what i do is i'll put them on their
knees
on the on the court and i'll have them
first we'll walk in the gym with the
ball in your fingertips underneath the
basket and you just
i let them see that this is all you need
and then then i'll let them get on their
knees on the floor
and then shoot from there and then just
let them work on that right there
because this this is all you need right
here if you're using your body this is
it's not a
heat you see a lot of people using their
shoulders and their lower body to try to
get the ball up there and that's where
form goes bad and then if you take that
bad form that's why a lot of people end
up not being able to shoot hey the
lakers are taking these old guys uh you
know you think do you think you could
give lebron uh you know
10 minutes a game
yeah i could give them i can give them
20 minutes a game the problem is that
next day i'm gonna be struggling a
little bit it's the recovery that gets
you uh more than anything that's all
right no no back-to-backs for you right
yeah no back-to-back you know it's great
now because i don't know if you know
this but i started coaching uh i'm the
head coach now gulliver prep down here
in miami
and uh so now
i get to work with these kids every
single day and you know get them to see
and understand you know their their best
potential because
you know physically i'll get on the
court with them and run up and down and
try and get them to you know be better
than they were yesterday and you know if
they go to college or not if they end up
going to pros or not whatever it may be
it's got to be you know uh high school
sports has to be a great experience for
our kids you know
when you're thinking about the drafts
and and international players around the
world they get drafted and we we got to
make sure that we make these experiences
for kids in high school the special
experience not not ruined by parents or
administrations but just special for
them that when they go there they feel
like man i had a great time playing on
that team when's the last time you went
into a room and you weren't the best
shooter in the room
um well it's always arguable it's been a
while um
listen i played in a golf tournament uh
last week uh with steph and dale
curry yeah so
you know depending on who who you're
asking you know that there's
i dale was one of my favorite shooters
you know all-time favorites and and
great so
um it is
we we had this conversation all the time
with uh buddies of mine we always talk
about
the greatest and we were actually having
this conversation about comedians last
night and they were trying to say who
the best comedian of all time was and
somebody said do you like
richard pryor or eddie murphy and i said
we don't get eddie murphy without
richard pryor
and so it's important that we understand
that a lot of who we try to compare like
the the next generation that comes along
we don't get without that
that previous player you know and that
is something you know all of us have
jordan dna in us we have dr j and magic
dna in us so to try to say we're better
or compared with any one of them is like
blasphemy
well you don't have trey young without
steph curry but you don't have steph
curry without you
yeah and it's just always it's a cycle
uh but it's almost like we're just so
focused on trying to say who's better
but it's just everybody has uh their own
purpose and that to me is uh
what's special and great about sports
uh the uh partnership is with abbott and
uh the maker of freestyle libre too ray
uh it's great to talk to you hope walker
does well and good luck uh coach in high
school
yeah thanks dan good seeing you take
care of that state up there for me i
know it's getting cold
you don't miss it at all
no no you don't all right thank you ray
we'll take a break we'll come back phone
calls after this